what was like in your opinion like a
moment for you that kind of changed
everything i feel like
to get right what it be was was a a you
know
i think that that was probably the first
yeah that was for sure like one of the
first
moments that people start paying
attention to my name as far as a
producer in the city
cause like well how did you guys meet
because you guys obviously didn't come
up together so how did you guys
initially meet
i heard that song and i'm like i asked
katelyn i'm like bro who made this
he put me on so i'm like link me you
need some more of this
and then you was like oh you could sing
yeah he just sent the song he didn't
even tell me like yeah bro i sing too he
just sent the song with some vocals on
there
turned out to be savage crazy
was that hard for you to like because
you know when you're a producer
you don't want to be like i'm the
producer who makes music because the
artist might look at you kind of crazy
if you're whacked you know what i'm
saying oh yeah
coming into the game is like a producer
you know was that something where it was
like you were kind of picking and
choosing like who you let
hear your [ __ ] it's kind of funny though
cause i don't i don't really look at
myself
oh no it's weird i don't know how other
people look at me but i look at myself
like an artist that produces
like kind of like a j cole right right
he's not heavily known for producing but
he got them accolades under his belt you
know and that's kind of how i want to
move
like if you know you know are you still
making beats for other people like not
that [ __ ] that you're not even on are
you still like sending packs out
yup yeah any any uh stuff that
you know might be coming or anything
yeah i got some crazy [ __ ] in the works
for sure